there's a calculation King G5 I take
with Knight GF Rook takes off five King
G4 Rook F1 and I'm threatening made in
two with Rook F4 King H3 Bishop F1
Checkmate and there's Rook G8 Rook F4
King H3 King H1 I don't think block is
stopping Bishop F1 let's go for this and
there's also a line uh King G5 takes
takes takes and then King G6
but then I'll be up two Pawns
okay so we're we're getting into this
and yeah I'm threatening made into and
Bishop one is usually a defensive move
oh this is exactly what I was
calculating so Rook F4
it's very important I have a Pawn on D4
if I had no Pawn on D4 if Rook G1 would
be checkmates and the block King took a
walk
and it entered the wrong neighborhood
okay that was a cool game